[Music]
one of the reasons that people resist
the idea that we are involve preachers
that we have a human nature is that it
seems to many people to - any hope for
social improvement the fear is that if
there's such thing as human nature you
can just dismiss attempts to reduce
violence to reduce greed to reduce
discrimination by saying oh it's just
human nature you'll never get rid of war
because he would serve generally more
like that leads people to say well there
better not be any human nature or else
we're going to each other's throats for
all eternity one of the points I made in
the book in the blank slate just in
passing was that's a non sequitur the
the fact that human nature exists
doesn't mean we have to behave in the
same way in perpetuity because human
nature is complex with it does have some
nasty bits there is such a thing as lust
and
selfishness revenge and dominance but we
also are equipped by evolution with
self-control with empathy with reason
with moral norms it's a question of how
the balance between those different
parts of human nature plays out in a
given time and place that determines how
we actually behave and I know that
almost in passing that I can't really be
a debate as to whether human nature
dooms us to a constant level of strife
because we just know looking at history
there
slavery was abolished Soviet empire
collapsed with violence and I know that
the rate of homicide had gone down
you know ever since the Middle Ages well
when I repeated these observations in a
blog post I started to get
correspondence from scholars in various
disciplines all over the world saying
well you could have added even more
examples of how violence declined you
know that rates of death and war have
come down over the last 70 years
you know the violence against women is
diced did you know that every European
country saw a drastic drop
interpersonal violence I realized
there's a big story here that very few
people are aware of that on many scales
of time and magnitude violence has been
a decline over the course of history so
not being a professional historian or
political scientist I realized that
still I was privy to all of these
sources of data from different
disciplines that deserve to be put in
one place so I wrote a book called the
battery stealing but as a psychologist
this decline of violence also posed the
challenge to me of explaining how it
happened why were so people people so
violent in the past how do they manage
to tame this violence to psychological
questions once I started to be open to
data on the course of human history then
I started to come across other datasets
showing that it wasn't just in case of
violence that
like better but we also bit longer we
are educated we more of us than in
democracies we have more leisure time
you move yourself in the headlines and
look at the data you see that's to you
an improvement poverty has been
decimated worldwide and I thought this
needed a book as well
extending the lesson about improvement
in peacefulness to improvement in other
measures of human flourishing and once
again the challenge of explaining it
were our human nature hasn't changed in
the last couple of centuries how do we
manage to improve human life there I
think ideas matter and one of the key
ideas that more sets of ideas one of the
ideas that we associate with the
Enlightenment the use of reason to
figure out the world as opposed to dogma
faith or Authority the attempt to
understand the physical world by
applying reason to it or call science
the ideal of humanism that what counts
morally is suffering and flourishing of
sentient creatures
including humans as a and that those
ideas when implemented were what peeked
out the progress that you could see in
the graphs for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you